jen after all these years fans are still
obsessive about ross and rachel but can
you believe that fans are still like
cooking up these dating rumors about you
and david schwimmer all of these years
later is it a little flattering is it a
little bizarre
well that was bizarre jennifer aniston
is responding to those david schwimmer
dating rumors that popped up shortly
after the friends reunion aired on hbo
max back in may back in high school i
had a
major crush on you
i know the 54 year old actress addressed
the dating speculation in a new
interview with e.t alongside her morning
show co-star reese witherspoon could not
believe that actually like really that's
my brother yeah but it was i mean i
understand though it just shows you how
hopeful people are for
fantasies
for dreams to come true
the romance rumors between jen and david
started swirling after the two admitted
during the reunion that they had crushes
on one another while they were filming
the iconic 90s sitcom jen as rachel
greene and david as ross geller
the first season yeah the first season
we i had a major crush on jen
um i
and yeah and i think it was we both
at some point we were both crushing hard
on each other but it was like two ships
passing because one of us was always in
a relationship
so and we never crossed that boundary a
source told et at the time of the
reunion that jen and david are not
currently dating and are not
romantically involved but the two former
co-stars do have something to celebrate
together because the reunion special
picked up four emmy nominations how
excited are you to go especially with
courtney finally
getting that long-awaited birth
nomination for friends so cute i mean
it's very exciting and we're really it
was kind of not even expected i mean
we're in the same category as hamilton
oh so that's not good that's what's epic
you know closes out into a broadway show
but um yeah that was very that was a
nice surprise as for reese she has
history with friends too she played one
of rachel's sisters
hi
is rachel here i'm her sister oh my god
jill oh my god rachel oh my god oh my
god introduce us
the oscar winner opened up to e.t about
the impact of the sitcom and reunion
special in her own life it was so moving
i i found it so emotional i cried three
times watching you guys you did yeah it
reminds me of a time in my life i know
so y'all lived it but we watched it and
it was it was important to me i remember
having a little baby and being a mom and
like going that was
you guys were my friends right and i
remember you i mean
that's the other thing going back and
watching reese like the clips of reese
and and and myself in the day we were
such babies ourselves we were really
cute but this is chandler hi and you
know monica and ross and that's phoebe
and that's joey hey how are you doing
don't
who knew our whole lives were sort of
ahead of us and it's just
crazy to think from there
here we sit so much happiness so much
look at you now from the green sisters
to alex and bradley huh that's right
flash forward to 2021 and jen and reece
are gearing up for season two of their
hit drama the morning show i'm not going
to get edged out alex levy
i feel like i'm bringing in my big
sister to clean up my mess in the series
the co-stars play news anchors alex levy
and bradley jackson jen told e.t this
season will tackle not just the drama
within the newsroom but also the anchors
handling the covet 19 pandemic when
exactly did you decide
to rework the season to really include
covet and things and how challenging was
it to have to relive it when we locked
down
is when we realized that
we had to go back to the drawing board
and figure out how do we incorporate
this into
the show
and also
figure out how to sort of delicately
weave it through because we didn't know
where we would be when the show aired if
we were out of covid and would people be
fatigued by hearing about kovid and
again watching all of the news shows try
to figure it out as we were tr as as a
new show about a show about a new show
watching them all try to figure out in
real time how do we handle this new
normal